one of the things I realized in doing
this film is jobs with a great
storyteller on great storytellers make
you forget about their failures there's
lots of failures you don't know anything
about them and you go what how is that
because they can manipulate you the
benchmark is set for CEOs is pretty
frightening not only do they have to be
able to do that kind of storytelling no
they also have to bit they often
literally walk in front of audiences and
perform with a microphone wrong there we
have to stroll around in casual clothes
they're clearly not built that way but
now if you can't launch a product like
that we may not want the product these
companies they will resist stories like
this because they what they want to keep
control of their mythology and it's
really important that artists hold on to
a and that can be in big political
ways or it can be in very personal ways
like this film during the time we're
having this interview uber will have
increased in value and it's an algorithm
it's not even a kind of manufacturer of
anything governments are unable to
resist these things now because they're
bringing prosperity there was so much
and you go all relax will you it's not
that big an issue is it's just the kind
of app for taxi drivers isn't it yes but
what appears to be almost entirely
benign and progressive can actually be
something that eats away at your freedom
and the in the pursuit of this
prosperity you become data you're no
longer an individual you're actually a
piece of information and that piece of
information can be shared and it can be
monetized my heroes are the Wikipedia
guys and the kind of tim berners-lee
guys who would partly invented the world
wide web and put it in trust so that no
corporation could own that with such an
influence over our lives and future
generations I'm really happy that there
are some heroes out there who've you've
done it for the good of all the book